Кримчаки, як кримські татари
і кримські караїми, —
це корінний народ.
Ми створилися як спільнота, як народ
саме на території сучасної України.
Ми ніколи не були багаточисленні.
У найкращі часи нас було
близько восьми тисяч.
З одного боку наша традиційна мова
дуже схожа на кримськотатарську,
у нас традиційна релігія — юдаїзм.
Люди, які є кримчаками,
у зв'язку з тим, що їх мало,
вони здебільшого
один для одного є родичами.
І у нас дуже довго була традиція,
напевне вона й зараз залишається в Криму.
Кожен кримчак на свій день народження
отримував листівку
від товариства кримчаків
з привітанням до дня народження.
Я не знаю жодної етнічної спільноти,
яка таке практикує.
Це дуже прикольно і дуже зворушливо.
Кримчаки станом на 1991 рік були в Криму.
І це частина української спільноти.
Ми ходили в 1991 році на референдум,
ми платимо податки,
наші діти йшли в [українську] армію.
Ми — частина українського суспільства.
Так, ми трохи інші, нас мало,
але це тільки підтверджує те,
що українське суспільство —
це сукупність різностей.
У мене бабуся з дідусем
інколи спілкувалися
кримчацькою мовою вдома.
Але так було смішно:
дідусь говорив кримчацькою,
бабуся інколи відповідала кримчацькою,
але зазвичай відповідала російською,
і я розумів контекст.
І деякі словосполучення,
я дізнався, що вони саме кримчацькою,
тільки коли вже пішов до школи.
Тобто до цього це була частина
мого лінгвістичного багажу,
я думав, що всі так знають.
Наприклад, у нас, коли людина
говорить щось про майбутній час,
то з поваги до Всевишнього,
враховучи, що тільки він знає,
що відбудеться,
і ти не можеш це знати.
З поваги до Всевишнього
ми кажемо: «Ксметл са».
Я був впевнений, що всі так роблять,
всі так кажуть.
А потім я дізнався про те,
що це наша мова.
Я люблю готувати,
тому я з мамою готував.
Але саме кубете — мама і бабуся.
Мама хоча й українка,
але деякі кримчацькі страви
вона все-таки готувала.
Коли почалися оці «зелені чоловічки»,
ми почали...
Декілька людей в Сімферополі...
Кожен ранок, о 3–4 ранку,
російські війська штурмували
наші українські військові частини.
Ми ж не знали тоді, що таке війна.
І ми думали, що якщо
ми станемо живим щитом
між м*скалями й українськими військами,
то вони не будуть штурмувати.
Зараз не оцінюйте той наш вчинок,
ми так думали,
ми були впевнені, що так спрацює.
Ми зрозуміли, що якщо ми не втечемо,
то нас поодинці знайдуть.
Тому ми взяли й роз'їхались.
Але у зв'язку з тим, що Львів —
це патріотичне місто,
декілька людей потрапили у Львів,
навіть не змовляючись про це.
Тому ми вирішили створити
громадський рух,
який називався «Кримська хвиля».
Я з Криму збираю інформацію,
і намагаюся якось її тут передавати
в Державну службу з етнополітики.
На різних конференціях,
якщо є можливість, виступаємо,
чи на круглих столах,
для того, щоб збільшити
інформацію про кримчаків.
Завдяки тому, що є Zoom i Skype,
є можливість онлайн зустрічатися,
зі своїми рідними спілкуватися.
А також і з людьми,
які можливо мені не є
кровними родичами,
але вони є кримчаками,
і у нас дуже багато спільних тем,
які ми можемо обговорювати.
— Привіт, Дороне! Мир вам!
— Хорошого дня! Мир вам!
Радий тебе бачити.
Ти, як рабин нашої громади,
як виходить зараз зібрати людей?
Чи готові вони збиратися для того,
щоб разом молитися, спілкуватися,
згадувати своїх близьких,
згадувати ту трагедію?
Ми, як народ кримчаків,
є хранителями
кримчацько-єврейської традиції.
Є чимало кримських євреїв,
які на своєму патріотичному початку
мають бажання молитися не за
якоюсь іншою традицією тут в Криму,
а сама за кримською традицією.
Будівля у нас буде,
і ми зможемо збиратись
більшим колективом, молитися.
Адже кожен кримчак може
спокійно приїхати в Україну,
є місце, де можна зупинитися.
Це один з найважливіших
політичних підходів:
показати відкритість України
до нашого народу.
Я вважаю, це можна розцінювати
як дуже вигідний політичний крок.
Якось прийшла до нас якась бабуся,
я її до того й після того не бачив.
Ця людина, вона вже старша була,
вона почула, що тут живуть
переселенці з Криму.
І вона принесла в клітчастій сумці
якісь консервації.
Боже, це було так зворушливо.
Слава Богу, нам було що їсти,
але саме цей жест був дуже зворушливий.
Думаю, ви ж уявляєте, яка в неї пенсія.
І людина так от поставилась.
І потім якісь чоловіки,
які теж бачили, що люди там живуть,
вони зверталися до мене, казали:
«У мене є якась картопля, візьми».
Тобто люди думали, що ми голодуємо,
слава Богу, що це було не так,
і слава Богу, що я приїхав до таких людей.
Ви розумієте?
Коли ти бачиш такий жест,
то ти розумієш, що ти в правильному місці.
Ті міста, куди переселились переселенці,
внутрішньо переміщені особи,
щоб вони стали трохи кращі,
саме через те,
що туди прийшли нові люди,
які допомагають розбудовувати
це місто чи село,
будь-яку громаду.
Це, мені здається, був би класний приклад,
в який спосіб можна склеювати державу.
Розуміти одне одного,
навіть якщо є певні різні погляди
на культуру чи на релігію,
все одно цінностей, те, що нас склеює,
їх набагато більше, ніж розбіжностей.
Бути кримчаком для мене
означає бути людиною,
яка пам'ятає, що Крим — це її дім.
Ми обов'язково маємо повернутись,
тому що це наш дім, розумієте?
І в залежності від віку дитини,
це розповідається різними словами,
але це завжди є частиною
нашої сімейної розмови.
Тому що, як би нам не хотілося,
діти, якщо з ними про щось не говорити,
вони про це забувають.
Навіть якщо для тебе це дуже важливо,
навіть якщо ти це завжди пам'ятаєш,
все одно з дітьми потрібно це артикулювати.
І ми це робимо.